♪♪♪
- [Jeff Johnson:] While a pandemic
swept through our world
and infected tens of millions—
- Last night it was the
NBA suspending its season
after Rudy Gobert of the Utah Jazz
tested positive for the coronavirus.
The league will use this hiatus
to determine the next steps
in dealing with the pandemic.
- I play for the fans.
That's what it's all about, so.
If I show up to an arena and
there ain't no fans in there,
I ain't playing, so.
They can do what they wanna do.
- We all talked shortly after
we shut down the season.
And of course, we've
always been looking for
whether or not there is an appropriate
and safe way in which we
can resume basketball.
- [Reporter:] Avery Bradley has decided
not to enter the bubble.
- [Reporter:] Trevor Ariza
opted out of the bubble.
- [Reporter:] That I heard.
- [Reporter:] Mavericks
center Willie Cauley-Stein
saying he's decided to sit
out the resumed NBA season.
- [Jeff J.:] Another crisis,
with roots hundreds of years long
and tied to our country's history,
brought Americans to the
streets demanding change.
Police killing George Floyd
had to mark a turning point.
- Police shootings and police
killing of African Americans
like myself, this isn't new.
It's just everyone has iPhones now,
so it's getting recorded.
- [Reporter:] It has been a painful night
of violence and protests in Minneapolis.
- It is your duty not to
burn your own house down
for anger with an enemy.
- [Reporter:] Breonna
Taylor, a 26-year-old EMT,
was shot eight times by police.
- [Protester:] Say her name!
- [Group:] Breonna Taylor!
- [Jeff J.:] Who was listening
to the Black community?
- I got brothers, I got
sisters, I got friends
that are in the streets, that are out here,
that haven't made it to this level,
that are experiencing it,
that are getting pulled
over. Just discrimination
day after day.
Dealing with the same, the same bullshit,
and this is systematic.
- [Jeff J.:] While the
coronavirus reared its head,
so did the realities of systemic racism.
- [Group:] George Floyd!
- [Jeff J.:] Long felt by
Black people in America
and too long ignored by so many others.
- To see all you guys come together
for one cause, for justice, for peace,
I'm just happy, man, and
I’ll try to join you guys,
but continue to stick together.
00:02:15,872 --> 00:02:16,705
- [Protester:] What do we want?
- [Group:] Justice!
- [Protester:] When do we want it?
- [Group:] Now!
- [Protester:] What do we want?
- [Group:] Justice!
- [Protester:] When do we want it?
- [Group:] Now!
- We need to take the time to go home
and figure out every single
person who represents us
and decide if they're
part of the problem
or part of the solution.
- [Jeff J.:] Meanwhile,
basketball moved into a bubble.
- Getting ready to take off to Orlando.
Check into this bubble.
- [Jeff J.:] Would this
bubble be a success?
♪♪♪
The country asked for
sports to bring healing.
- I chose Black Lives Matter
because Black lives matter.
- [Jeff J.:] Black Lives Matter on buses,
on the court, on jerseys.
- A lot of people
kinda use this analogy,
talking about Black Lives
Matter is a movement.
It's not a movement.
When you Black, it's not a movement.
It's a lifestyle.
- [Jeff J.:] The league
promised to say their names,
to say her name.
Justice for Breonna.
- I want her family to know,
and I want the state of Kentucky to know,
that we feel for it and we want justice.
- I have pretty much every possible name
of someone that's died
from police brutality
or police violence,
and on the back too.
- [Jeff J.:] But the
change that is necessary,
many wondered if its
momentum would be lost
inside the walls of a new arena.
When players said there
was not enough changing,
basketball stopped.
[Buzzer]
- Breaking news now:
NBA television has just announced
that the Milwaukee Bucks
are boycotting the NBA playoff game
that is scheduled to happen right now.
- Our focus today cannot be on basketball.
- We are calling for
justice for Jacob Blake
and demand the officers
be held accountable.
- You know, you watch a guy get shot
in front of his entire family,
and then right underneath
that video is somebody saying,
"Hey, well, he should've
just listened to the police."
So, like, you take all that in,
whether you register it or not,
whether you realize what
you're looking at or not,
you're taking that in, and
that depreciation of life,
and, you know, kinda the—you get numb
to what you're looking at,
and you almost start to question yourself.
- As a Black man, as a former player,
I think it's best for me
to support the players
and just not be here tonight.
- [Jeff J.:] They demanded change.
- We're not trying to defund the police
and take all their money away.
We're trying to get them to protect us,
just like they protect everybody else.
- The job isn't done yet.
And we can't stop until
Black lives really do matter.
- [Jeff J.:] They sought justice.
They urged us to vote.
- Hopefully, the initiatives
that we came together,
that we partnered with, voting and sites
and arenas and things of that nature,
hopefully years on down the line,
America is in a better place,
that you can look back to
this moment and be like,
"That was one of the catapults
that kinda got it going."
- I'm proud to announce that we have
over 90 percent of our league registered to vote.
Fifteen teams are 100 percent registered.
And the job that guys have been doing
just to be a little bit more
educated on the situations
and getting people out,
recruiting poll workers
and things like that,
the bubble has been an
unbelievable blessing.
Our players are continuing to do the work,
and we're grateful, and
we're gonna keep working.
- [Jeff J.:] Can we call
this bubble a success?
- I think the biggest thing
was us being able to
come together as a group
and try to figure out ways to
continue to impact society.
I think we’ve continued to do that,
and hopefully we continue to uplift
and put light on some of the injustices
that we're seeing in America.
- We came down here for a reason,
and obviously to win a championship,
but to spread the message.
We stopped playing and continued playing
because we're gonna continue
to preach our message,
not just for the game.
But I'm very happy with
the way things went
as far as being able to
come back on the floor
and the NBA and the owners
and us agreeing on certain things.
And I hope this,
as these playoffs go,
as everybody watches,
we continue to push what's
really needed in this world.
- It was challenging.
It was well put-together.
The NBA and the teams and the players
did a hell of a job sacrificing.
We used our platform for
our voices to be heard
in the social injustices.
Getting guys to go out there to vote.
Justice for Breonna Taylor.
Justice for everybody,
every Black American out there
that are being harmed by
police and police brutality.
- [Jeff J.:] There are still questions,
but we are listening.
- My skin color should not
determine whether I live or die.
This is a human civil right
crisis that's going on.
- The game was great.
We won by two.
But at the end of the day,
Breonna Taylor's killers are still free.
There are so many different things
that we can honestly talk about.
I'm gonna continue to
talk about Breonna Taylor
cuz that's near and dear to me.
- One thing for me is that
Breonna Taylor’s killers
still are roaming around free.
So I think I just wanna focus on that
with these interviews
and things like that.
So I just wanna keep the focus there.
- We wanna make sure that Daniel Cameron
will arrest the cops and the officers involved
with Breonna Taylor's death.
- My answer is gonna be
justice for Breonna Taylor.
That's gonna be my answer for everything.
So I'm just letting
you guys know that now.
- [Tobias Harris:] That's gonna be
my answer for every question.
- [Interviewer:] Fair enough.
- For Daniel Cameron to step
up and to do what's right,
and that's the only
message I got today.
I appreciate everybody. Thanks.
- [Interviewer:] Thanks, T.
- [LeBron James:] Where do we go from here?
We don't stop.
Obviously when the season ends
in less than a week,
that everyone disperses and goes back,
but I hope that people
continue to use their platform,
use their individual
social media platforms
if they're doing it that way,
if you're an individual that
goes into your community
and does it that way,
however that you can continue to create change
for the better of all of us.
I think it only makes us all better.
- [Protester:] Say her name!
- [Group:] Breonna Taylor!